all right so as i said the big story in
the media world last week was chris
cuomo the actor pretending to be a
journalist who was on prime time over at
cnn uh he was fired finally uh this was
not an act of cancel culture you know it
was funny i was thinking about it over
the weekend it's like we have so many
people who get fired or lose their jobs
unjustly right because of cancer culture
this is a rare example of a guy getting
fired for the right reasons like he was
in complete dereliction of his duty as a
journalist he was altering and somewhat
hiding stories there's evidence of it
because they were related to his brother
and info that he didn't want to get out
there so he's he's fully justified her
cnn is fully justified in their firing
of him but what's been interesting about
this is that uh cnn is almost sorta
kinda could they be maybe looking in the
mirror does stelter have a mirror we
know he doesn't have a scale but maybe
he has a mirror uh he did a segment on
uh the
cuomo firing and how that reflects on
cnn you know the biggest media story
this weekend it's the firing of chris
cuomo from this network cnn now i've
been working the phones ever since this
was announced yesterday uh evening
frankly i've been on the phone to the
last five minutes here getting
information about what happened and
where cnn goes from here ultimately this
is about trusted media as sarah was
referring to trusted media has cnn lost
trust as a result of this arabic
well you know i don't know that's hard
to say if cnn has lost trust here's the
problem we've really lost sense of media
ethics in our profession especially in
the last few years you have to ask
yourself first and this is the mistake
that chris cuomo made and in some sense
i think cnn made this same mistake and
not forcing him nasa's who do you work
for who do you serve
obviously you serve and you work for
your employer or you don't get a check
but beyond that
where who are you talking to you should
be serving the public so that's the
thing
i think this is a once in a lifetime
ethical dilemma that doesn't let's try
to let off my about the hook but there's
never going to be another moment like
this where there's a brother as an
anchorman of a governor in the middle of
covid and you know one of them gets
covey like this was a once-in-a-lifetime
situation that doesn't mean that
everyone knows i did the right things at
the right time but it was unique
all right so first off credit where
credit is due i will give stelter a
little credit for even doing this
segment right just
i'll get to what he said there at the
end where he you know sort of moves the
goal posts on it but like just for doing
the segment i'll give the guy like a
certain amount of credit the guest there
made a good point uh that media ethics
have been completely trampled on there
basically are no media ethics anymore um
i can tell you this that at this point
and i did one of these last week when a
mainstream publication reaches out to me
which they reach out to me several times
a week to get
they want quotes from me or they maybe
want to do a story on me or they want to
do a story on a friend of mine i almost
always know it's a hit piece almost
always and usually i just write back
something like you are not a journalist
you're an activist or you know something
to that effect and i say you can put
that on the record and then they don't
print anything so i will give stelter a
little bit of credit there and i'll also
give the guests the credit for saying
hey we've failed we in the media have
failed because so many of us right you
guys watching this you know how badly
they felt now what's interesting and
this is where stelter fails is he's
asking the question like oh did have we
harmed our trust like have we not been
acting as good as we should have and
it's like well hey that's obvious right
like that's just obvious but like if you
just went through the list of things
that cnn has lied about over the last
say three years that is far
far bigger than chris cuomo who will
just be a footnote irrelevant piece of
history right they lied about brett
kavanaugh being a serial rapist remember
that was every single day on cnn 24
hours a day they lied about jesse smilet
being lynched remember that and now
they're not even really covering the
trial of jesse smallette right now
because it would expose all their lies
in the first place which is another type
of fake news the type of fake news is
when you promote a lying story but then
another type of fake news is when you
won't cover something because it also
goes against your narrative so that's a
double lie on smallet they lied
endlessly about the russia hoax
endlessly they lied about hunter biden
and the laptop and we weren't allowed to
talk about it they lied about the
covington kids being racist and then uh
who's who's the kid the main kid the
main covington kid
the maine covington kid
yo nick sam man thank you nick salman
won a big lawsuit against cnn because of
that they lied about
kyle house they lied about the very fine
people hoax where trump did
condemn the white supremacists and the
neo-nazis so you guys have lied about
about like all of the stuff that has
mattered culturally in and politically
and you will continue to lie and we'll
know you're lying and you'll know you're
lying and yet you'll continue to lie
right well you know all that so this is
where stelter doesn't get credit cause
it's like i'll give you credit you did a
segment you sorted it and he's been on
the phone a lot and my god okay fine you
did the segment you got called out on
media ethics which you don't have you
don't seem to be aware of all the other
things that you've lied about or that
you lie about by omission and then
finally there at the end when he's
trying to clean it up and he's like this
is this is a once-in-a-lifetime thing i
mean an anchor and his brother and a
pandemic well first off once in a
lifetime this pandemic's been going on
for two years so let's just remove this
pandemic has been going on for two years
let's just remove pandemic but the idea
of a brother reporting on his brother i
mean almost everyone at all of these
networks is either related to or a
cousin of or married to or a former
staffer of or something to someone that
used to be in an administration
somewhere george stephanopoulos the
chief
abc news correspondent with his sunday
show used to be a bill clinton staffer
right it's like we all know all of these
things the the people that uh fail in
government go on to all of these shows
and then they either protect their ass
from [ __ ] that they did before like you
get it you get like what a giant snake
eating circle jerk it is i think we all
get it uh so stelter i tried to give you
a little bit of credit there but i can't
give you that much credit anyway i don't
think we're gonna have to we'll have to
talk about this story anymore because
cuomo is gone and the point is that i
mentioned last week it's like he
deserved to go because of the the
dereliction of duty but also had they
brought him back it would have been like
wait a minute there are so many other
people out there that would kill for
that job and don't you people always
tell us how racist and homophobic the
world is and why wouldn't you hire a gay
black lesbian to do that job that would
be the best thing that you could do so
we hope
my hope is that cnn will live up to its
diversity and inclusion standards and
picked whoever is the most oppressed
journalist in the world we must find
that person what whoever is winning the
oppression olympics because of their
ableism or their disableism and the
color of their skin and their religion
and their sexuality and their gender
identity i want to he himself
like the full thing on cnn that's what i
want
don lemon to throw to